this justtin President Biden has arrived
here in New York City with tensions High
over the growing migrant crisis Federal
authorities thought they had found four
of the migrants involved in the NYPD
beat down all the way out in Arizona but
we are now learning it wasn't them and
most of the alleged attackers are still
on the loose CB cotton joining us live
here in studio with Mor CB what do we
know exactly at this point hi sander
what we've learned from our colleague
Griff Jenkins some of the men picked up
by federal immigration officers on a
phoenix bound bus are not the men
suspected in the assault on a pair of
NYPD officers so it's still believed
some of the migrant men who were charged
and released last week are headed out
west to the California Mexico border CBP
confirms to Fox it issued warrants for
three of the men Gomez Isel wz and
Serita roacha the only suspect who is
being held on bail in New York in this
case yo Henry burrito is set to be
arraigned on a grand jury indictment
next month when the charges for his
alleged role in the in the assault will
be unsealed buredo had a brief court
appearance yesterday for two prior
misdemeanor cases his attorney saying
after his client pleaded not guilty this
case highlighting the sanctuary city
laws which limit New York City agencies
in their involvement with ice New York
city mayor Eric Adams said this week
it's a matter for city council to take
up and just yesterday he said he
supports deportations in these
instances it is my strong belief that if
a person commit a serious crime felony
violent crime of the federal government
should do this job and Deport that
individual if they're found guilty now
New York Republican lawmakers have
pinned this letter to New York Governor
Kathy hokel calling for Manhattan
district attorney Alvin Bragg to be
removed saying his handling of this
assault must be the quote final straw
and adding quote the public safety of
New Yorkers is clearly at risk so the
DA's office tells us the worst offenders
and the brutal attack have yet to be
have yet to be arrested and reportedly
they're now reviewing police body camera
footage to further investigate this case
uh we will keep watching that very
closely I know you will CB thank you I'm
Steve duy I'm Brian kilme and I'm angle
airheart and click here to subscribe to
the Fox News YouTube page to catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis